Horus isis tefnut osiris and hathor
to hear the account of khonshu
Welcome back everyone this will be my full marvel
moon knight episode 3 video there's a whole bunch
of easter eggs we'll break it all down things
just got crazy we just wound up meeting some of
the other gods in the mcu through their avatars
so if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes we're also
doing a giveaway for memberships all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moments from the episode on the video
and careful for spoilers if you have not seen
episode 3 yet because we'll be talking about
everything starting with the episode title the
friendly type it's a bit of a sly wink about them
introducing some of the friendlier gods implying
that there are a lot worse ones out there and
there are worse ones inside the mcu remember it's
a very vast universe and each different culture
has their own group of gods their own pantheons
so khonshu the ennead the mcu here is only one
group of the gods thor is part of the asgardian
pantheon of gods all the different other gods
that we met in this episode were actually through
their avatar so they spoke to their avatars but
the voices that you hear are the voices of their
avatars like when kanchi was speaking through
marc spector taking over his body you're still
hearing oscar isaac's voice speak as khonshu
when he speaks as himself inside marc spector's
head or in stephen grant's head is actually
the voice of f murray abraham that's his actual
voice the same is true for all the other gods too
eventually we will probably meet some of the other
gods in their true form probably one of the best
parts of the episode though is witnessing them
each use some of their different powers in the
way they can combine their powers to become even
stronger like the mcu gods going full voltron by
our powers combined the opening scene is actually
of layla complaining to a forger that's been
working with her family and her father for a long
time and seems to have known her for a long time
she's in the middle of getting a new fake id going
back into egypt the way she talks about it she's
kind of like an indiana jones type of figure like
she dealt in stolen antiquities but the way she
talks about it is the way that indiana jones talks
about stealing antiquities oh it's only stealing
from bad people that's also reference to what's
going on with midnight man who shows up later in
the episode don't worry i'll talk about him too
i know there are a couple questions about what's
going on with his character because the actor who
plays him also passed away in real life so there
was a lot of talk about that the date on her fake
passport is 5 29 2019 then we'll put it around the
time of avengers end game in the blip but it is a
fake passport so you could put any date you want
to on that that's not meant to be any direct comic
book reference or anything like that what they've
done for her character is they sort of combined
the marlene comic book love interest character
with her father but they do reference the father
figure in this who's a version of the comic book
father who himself was an archaeologist the
ten years she refers to burning bridges is a
reference to that indiana jones style backstory
with her dealing with stolen antiquities and
running afoul a lot of these black market people
like the midnight man they also referenced her
doing a lot of this in madra poor a long time
ago so that's another connection to falcon and
winter soldier the other stuff that's going on
in the mcu right now too mad rapport actually
comes out of the x-men comics but in the mcu so
far as we learned from falcon and winter soldier
it's a big port of call for villains in the mcu
there were some wolverine easter eggs in that
like the bar that they go to is the same bar from
the wolverine comics where madrid poor appeared
they make a couple references to her father dying
previously in the events of what happened with
marc spector's first death in the mcu becoming
moon knight his bargain with khonshu for the first
time so it's all sort of tied up together they'll
reveal more of that backstory in future episodes
when they show you her passport they also show
you this picture of the pyramids it's meant to
foreshadow them traveling to the inside of the
great pyramid of giza where they have this big
council of the gods but the other connection
when they talk about the overvoid like khonshu
talks about the overvoid in the episode that's the
alternate pocket dimension where all the gods that
are part of khonshu's pantheon went after they
departed mankind and left the main mcu dimension
the place in the other void where they all reside
is shaped like the great pyramid of giza and the
interior looks like it because they designed it
to look like the place that they used to inhabit
when they were inside the main mcu dimension like
you see all the gods avatars here sitting around
here there's nine members because there's nine
members sitting on the enid in all the history
books that stephen is reading during episode one
they play some new egyptian themed music while
the marvel studios logo plays just to let you know
that you're traveling to actual egypt and you see
arthur harrow's men find ammit's tomb in what's
going on here with them in the desert finding this
tomb is meant to be a reference to the classic
origin story with marc spector dying the first
time in the egyptian sands fighting against
bushman who was trying to pilfer conchus too
like they've hinted at on the show a version
of that happened in the comics although some of
the characters are a little bit different they're
giving all the bushmen story to arthur harrow they
kind of referenced that in last week's episode
where they talk about all these archaeologists
winding up dying and blaming it on marc
spector like no he was the one that killed all
these people when really it was probably arthur
harrow's men that killed all those archaeologists
and that's probably the event where he became moon
knight for the first time where he died and then
kancho made the bark with him bringing him back to
life there's a new fight sequence just to show you
what marc spector's skills are as a mercenary
in real life like he is a really good fighter
because they want to show you what it looks like
when he is not using konju's power as moonlight
because he basically loses that temporarily at the
end of this episode but they also hint that there
might be another personality which i think is a
big comic book easter egg too so a lot of you are
probably asking about this like wait a minute
they're talking about another personality does
that mean that jake lockley is going to surface on
the show at some point but they do have this big
rooftop chase around cairo to show you some of the
city because we've never actually been here in the
mcu before we have been in the marvel movies if
you count the fox x-men movies because they spent
a lot of time in egypt during x-men apocalypse
where oscar isaac himself played a version of
apocalypse who claims to be the very first mutant
on planet earth maybe there'll be some jokes about
that in the future because moonite is kind
of like a deadpool style character with all
the wisecracking the whole idea earlier in the
episodes though is that when they switch between
personalities usually it's because of some sort
of head trauma or some fight that they get into
or something happens to them causing the change
slowly we'll see over time though that they start
to do this willingly there are a couple times
we've seen them willingly give each other control
of the body during this time jump he wakes up
after steven grant seems like he forced some sort
of bargain with them even though later after he
chases them down and winds up having another time
jump waking up with one of them dead at the point
of his knife so when steven starts referencing
this mystery third potential personality i think
that's meant to be a jake lockley reference and i
think at some point in the next couple of episodes
we will learn about the other personalities inside
him from the comics so in the comics currently
there's at least five different personalities
but one of the big differences is that in the
comics the mr knight persona is portrayed as being
a completely separate personality from stephen
grant in the show they're doing mr knight as if
he's just the moon knight form of stephen grant
if you're not a long time moon knight comic book
reader jake lockley was kind of like the matches
malone version of moon knight to make a batman
reference he was meant to be a gruff cab driver
who was used for information gathering purposes
kind of like marc spector has been doing during
this episode trying to find out where arthur
harrow is so they can find ahmed's tomb stephen
grant calls concho a stupid pigeon talking about
his bird-like skull head on top of the humanoid
shoulders khonshu then literally tells marc
spector what winds up happening during the episode
foreshadowing everything he says oh okay we call
the other gods to help with this problem they
might wind up imprisoning me which they do during
the episode khonshu also references his healing
factor that he gets when they're connected when
he's his avatar moon knight's sailing factor works
about as fast as wolverines and it's similar to
wolverines and they both feel the damage like it
hurts them when people attack them but they heal
really fast because it's daylight you see what
it looks like when konshu departs marc spector
remember even though it seems like he disappears
really all of konshu walking around him talking
to him appearing here is happening inside marc
spector's head that's why nobody else can see him
it's part of the rules that govern the way they
exist inside the mcu across different dimensions
they just banish him from the idiot they don't
banish him into the mcu or anything like that
it's similar to thor but thor got banished to
earth khonshu just got banished to a different
part of the pocket dimension that's outside
of the mcu they kind of explained that in last
week's episode like he has a limited ability to
interact with the mcu without using his avatar
that's why he has to funnel his power through
steven grant at the end of the episode in mr
night form to turn the night sky back they explain
a little bit more about the idiot having different
meetings with their different avatars over time
anytime we call a meeting they'll open up a portal
anywhere you are so a portal opens up right next
to him in a doorway and he walks into the great
pyramid of giza so if it wasn't clear the portal
leads him directly into the actual mcu interior of
the great pyramid of giza like they're inside the
actual pyramid itself when he says the last time
he spoke to the other gods that are a member of
this pantheon they banished him that's probably
a reference to when they first imprisoned ahmet
thousands of years ago about 2 000 years ago
and turned away from mankind heading to the other
void so it sounds like all those things happened
around the same time the way they talk about it
he just did something that was big enough to alert
people to their presence kind of the way that
he affects the night sky is that all the people
of cairo here in this area like a wide group of
people can see what's actually going on like wait
a minute what is thanos back what's going on here
what kind of cosmic craziness is happening now
but that's basically what happens when he affects
the night sky to call the mcu enemy like he says
oh this will get their attention so he tries to
piss them off so that they will be the ones to
call this council and like i said even though it
seems like this would be happening all over the
world everybody would be seeing this really only
the people in the area of egypt here around cairo
can see what's happening to the night sky so for
example this is set after the events of spider-man
no way home so theoretically spider-man is
swinging around new york city stopping criminals
in his friendly neighborhood spider-man costume
he wouldn't turn up and look at the sky and see
what's going on here from new york city but it
might be powerful enough to set off his spidey
sense like wait a minute why is my spidey sense
going off is something crazy about to happen so in
the episode if it wasn't clear this is more of a
smoke and mirrors visual kind of thing they're not
actually sending everything on the planet back in
the timeline there are nine statues sitting around
this ring here because there are nine members
of the mcu enid referenced earlier in episode
one when stephen grant was reading the history
book the woman says her name is yatsel she's the
avatar of hathor and explains that hathor used to
be friends or is friends with khonshu even though
khonshu doesn't spend a lot of time talking about
his time with the pantheon 2000 plus years ago
it's also a really good example of how a lot of
the different gods that are part of this pantheon
of the country comes from do not agree with each
other they have sort of a loose alliance they kind
of police themselves one of the other things they
do in the episode too is show you how all these
different avatars are different types of people
from different cultures so the avatars of each
of the gods can be from any culture on earth it's
more about each of the people winding up having
minds that are compatible with the gods that want
them to be avatars the way they talk about khonshu
in the episode he sort of dominates his avatars
in a really abusive kind of way and that's not
meant to be a lie it really is like that for marc
spector in the comics but also the way that arthur
harrow talks about in the episode ethan hawke's
character it was like that for him as well like
he broke arthur harrow when he was his avatar and
that led to a lot of what's happening in present
day so khonshu wind up pulling himself a big
spider-man problem spider-man usually causes all
the big problems that he winds up having to solve
in each of his big movies if he hadn't broken
arthur harrow spirit he wouldn't have looked to
a healing hand and ahmed would have been able to
take advantage of that and present this solution
so one of the big things in the episode is arthur
harrow completely believing everything he's saying
so he's technically not lying he's only lying
about what ahmed is planning to do and trying to
release her everything he's talking about khonshu
is meant to be true but the other gods that are
present in this council meeting are just horus
isis osiris and tefna so all the gods aren't here
le concho's father atum is not here he's meant
to be the leader of their pantheon the reason
why osiris speaks first then horus is because
they're some of the more significant gods in their
pantheon like each god is a little bit different
not all are created equal also like i said khonshu
just does not get along with the other gods the
same way in the thor movies you see the other gods
like odin for example be really pissed off at thor
thus he takes over marc's body directly and the
gods start yelling at each other anytime you see
their eyes light up white that means that the gods
are acting directly through them using them like
finger puppets we get a little more information on
what's going on with this pantheon of gods in the
mcu they say that when they departed earth the
reason why they have avatars is only to observe
never act on anything which is another reason
why this pantheon of gods didn't do anything
to stop thanos during avengers end game and they
probably didn't do anything to try and stop kang
during the multiverse war very much a not our
problem kind of situation like i said they're
outside of the mcu dimension now so they're really
protected from any kind of changes inside the mcu
which is why thanos and the infinity gauntlet
did not affect them because thanos was only
using the infinity gauntlet on things inside
the mcu dimension and i think the whole idea
with arthur harrow being able to deceive the
other gods as to his true intentions so easily
is another good example of how limited their
ability is inside the mcu while they themselves
are trapped in this other alternate dimension
if all the gods were physically inside the mcu
talking to him they would probably be able to see
his entire timeline and know instantly whether
he's telling the truth or whether he's lying like
i said though everything that arthur harrow says
is true except for wanting to release ahmed he
lies about that but everything he says about
marc spector having multiple personalities in his
body about khonshu being terrible to him when he
was his avatar and now being terrible to marc
spector abusing him is completely true you kind
of notice that each of the different avatars when
he's wielding the power of these different gods
kind of glows white their eyes glow white when
they manipulate their hands using projectile
powers it glows white inside the mcu they try to
color code different types of magic just to denote
the different places where they get their power
from and how the different power works really
what i'm looking forward to seeing is during the
series seeing the actual gods in their true forms
used power themselves but after he gets thrown
into the bus and the gods sort of side with arthur
harrow hathor then explains through her avatar
what's going on with midnight man and the location
of senfu's remains in the map that will help them
locate ammit's remains the layla shows up finding
him it sounds like he tried to duck her earlier
coming to egypt on his own without telling her
he kind of explains what's going on with khonshu
and trying to push her away in what's going on
with steven grant his alternate personalities the
mogart that they reference where they're headed is
a reference to mcu midnight man who is a comic
book character the actor actually did pass away
after they filmed this which is very unfortunate
in the comics midnight man was an art thief who
wound up dying and then coming back to life in the
moonlight comics and trying to become his sidekick
unsuccessfully the character called bec that she
winds up talking to is a version of karish beck
from the moonai comics who was a minor character
that he fought during his first comic solo series
a long time ago they mentioned her backstory in
madrapur like i said that's probably a reference
to her indiana jones stuff that she's been doing
in the mcu dealing in stolen antiquities when they
joke about the l mermaid games that's actually
an ancient egyptian version of the gladiator
games in real life it's that game that they're
playing riding around swinging the big sticks
at each other and when marc spector isn't able
to explain the greater significance of senfu's
tomb his sarcophagus or any of the ancient
egyptian hieroglyphics or decipher the map i think
that's meant to be another example about each of
the different personalities in him going forward
will be more useful to each other and they'll
work together because stephen grant is the one
who has access to all their collective knowledge
on egyptian history even though technically it's
the same mind like it's the same body that they
share but the way these different personalities
work each one has access to different parts
of information contained inside their brain
we kind of see a version of that unfold where they
switch back and forth based on what's happening
with the big action scenes when arthur harrow
shows up and starts talking about everything that
happened to layla in her history and what happened
to her father she's all confused about how
he's able to do that one of the reasons why her
power works the way that it does is because she
existing in this higher dimension like a lot of
the other mcu gods basically perceives the entire
timeline of everyone is the single point so she
can see everything in your history in your future
as if it's all happening at the same time and
as her avatar arthur harrow's kind of tapping
into that power so he knows things that she's
done that she hasn't told to anyone the reason
why arthur harrow destroys the sarcophagus
in the body even though it's a very valuable
cultural artifact is so moon knight will not find
out the location of ammit's remains we get a much
bigger moon knight action scene they show off much
more of his powers you see him use the costume and
the cape to block the bullets he also uses it to
reflect the bullets back at the henchmen he's got
a measure of super speed super strength he's way
more vicious but a lot of that is actually coming
from marc spector himself i think part of the
idea is that all the most violent parts of their
personality got funneled into this marc spector
part of his personality and stephen grant got
all the more tender aspects of his personality but
if it wasn't clear when he was explaining them to
layla essentially he's had multiple personalities
since he was a young child he just got the stephen
grant one suppressed inside him this whole
time until he died and then came back to life
because of khonshu there's a couple jokes about
them switching between different personalities
because steven grant doesn't like violence so he
keeps yelling at him to stop then switches into
mr knight form when stephen takes control but then
immediately gets impaled and is like nope yep not
having it you take over again and gives the body
back to marc spector with him switching back and
forth between the different costumes to denote the
different personalities taking over it's a little
bit like that in the comics too like he can switch
on a dime layla's necklace winds up being a little
bit like moon knight's crescent darts like he
pulls the crescent darts out of his chest and uses
them kind of like batarangs she's able to detach
her necklace and uses his two different weapons
they play it like midnight man gets killed by moon
knight during the episode i think mostly because
they wanted him to win the fight but also because
the actor passed away in real life so they had to
sort of address that with this scene during the
episode layla asking for steven's help assembling
the star chart is another example of the show
just reminding you why all the personalities will
eventually have to learn to work together this
is also the first time we've seen marc spector
willingly give control of their body back to
steven grant like okay fine it's yours we get
another tutorial on egyptian history all this
stuff about ancient egyptians inventing modern
navigation using the stars and constellations
instead of traditional landmarks is true
he forms the map of the different stars in
the night sky into an actual giant star they
talk about the night 2000 years ago when the gods
trapped amid khonshu says that he remembers every
night since then he sounds kind of sad like he's
sad that the gods turned away from man and the big
riff that happened with them going to this other
pocket dimension and it sounds like since the end
of the trial he knew exactly how this would go
down like okay we're going to have to actually
do it this way turn back the night sky i'll get
trapped and steven will have to get marc's help
in releasing me so we get our powers back so like
i explained even though it seems like everybody
around the world might see what's happening in
the night sky it's more of a visual cosmetic thing
that's kind of localized to this area around cairo
and egypt so spider-man other mcu characters the
avengers characters who are in the united states
probably don't know what's happening we get a
tutorial about what it looks like when the gods
combine their powers voltron style they become
even more powerful but they're all acting through
their avatars so remember this is just a fraction
of their power if they all physically came back
into the mcu they would be way way more powerful
my early theory is that this is part of the way
they end the series doing something similar to
ammit because she's super powerful she has a
ton of followers making her even more powerful
eventually khonshu mind up working with them
they combine their power to help collectively
defeat her part of the idea with mcu gods is
you can't really kill a god the exact same way
you can kill their physical body that they exist
in like they're trapping their giant cosmic
essence into this tiny physical body you can get
rid of the body but you can't really kill their
essence that's why you kind of have to trap them
it's like watching odin die in the mcu he turns
into pure odin force like even though his body
disintegrates he himself technically isn't dead
because he then speaks to thor after this from
valhalla which for them for the asgardian pantheon
is kind of like another pocket dimension they
also kind of throw the idea of death for humans
in the mcu on its head with moon knight as
well because he legit died khonshu brought his
body back to life when he became his avatar they
forged the bargain so there's a ton of mythology
that they're introducing in this series they
haven't fully explained yet but that's part of
what i'm trying to do in my bonus videos and
they'll clarify some of these plot points and
some of the greater cosmic mythology in future
episodes too it's like every time we get a new
episode they answer a couple questions it just
raises even more questions when the avatar of
osiris is talking to arthur harrow talking about
trapping khonshu now he's tethered to this place
inside the great pyramid of giza like many
before him he's talking about regular people
having their souls entombed in this place but
also he's implying that this has happened to
other really powerful cosmic beings god level
creatures that are part of their pantheon the gods
themselves can actually have biological children
the same way that regular people have children
so really the idiot is more like a ruling council
over their particular pantheon of collective gods
and like i said arthur harrow at the end of
the episode is not lying when he's talking to
khonshu and the rock about pain just in general
he enjoyed being conscious avatar dealing out
pain while doing conscious justice and he thinks
that's a huge sin that he has to carry with him
in a tone for and that's probably how ammit was
able to take advantage of him remember arthur
harrow said two thousand plus years ago when they
trapped ahmed her own avatar turned against her so
something similar might wind up happening with
ethan hawk's character but it is only going to
get more crazy pants from here like we're going
to see way more god-tier power because remember
when he says he's going to do what khonshu could
not he's just talking about getting rid of all
evil theoretically eventually everyone would think
about something evil at some point and that would
be enough to wind up getting you killed by ammit
so she'd wind up killing every theoretical living
being inside the mcu eventually and it'd be just
like avengers end game with thanos trying to wipe
the entire universe and start over again here we
go again but if you spotted any other huge easter
eggs in the episode that i didn't talk about in
the video just write them below in the comments
my moon knight episode 4 trailer video will post
next in my full episode 4 video we'll post next
week just like normal everyone click here to
learn how moon knight is connected to mcu black
knight blade ghost rider and werewolf by night
we're going to see them cross over real soon
and click here for my new doctor strange 2
trailer videos with brand new easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!